what in your views
are the pros and cons of capitalism
as it's implemented in america i don't
know if you would say capitalism is
really exist in america
but to the extent that it does people
use the word capitalism in in so many
different ways
what is capitalism the literal meaning
is private ownership of capital goods
which i favor in most areas but no i
don't think the private sector should
own our f-16s or military assets
government-owned water utilities seem to
work as well as privately owned water
utilities
but with all those qualifications put to
the side
business for the most part innovates
better than government it is oriented
toward consumer services
the biggest businesses tend to pay the
highest wages
business is great at getting things done
usa
is fundamentally a nation of business
and that makes us a nation of
opportunity
so i am indeed mostly a fan subject to
numerous caveats
what's uh what's the con what's what are
some negative
downsides of capitalism in your view
or some things that we should be
concerned about maybe for long-term
impacts of capitalism again capitalism
takes a different form in each country i
would say in the united states
our weird blend of whatever you want to
call it
has had an enduring racial problem from
the beginning
has been a force of taking away land
from native americans and oppressing
them
pretty much from the beginning um
it has done very well by immigrants for
the most part
uh we revel in creativity and creative
destruction more
so we don't just prop up national
champions forever
and there's a precariousness to life for
some people here that is less so
say in germany or the netherlands we
have weaker communities in some regards
than say northwestern europe
often would that has pluses and minuses
i think it makes us more creative
it's a better country in which to be a
weirdo than say germany or denmark
but there is truly whether from the
government
or from your private community there is
less social security
in some fundamental sense
you